das ist klaus wir sind heute im klaus
küche klaus zeigt uns gegenstände in der
küche was ist das ein kühlschrank
was macht man mit dem kühlschrank im
kühlschrank bewahrt man lebensmittel
auch hier drin im kühlschrank richtig
was ist das das ist ein herz klaus macht
den herd auf noch heiß
warum ist der herd heiß mit dem herd
kann man backen
was ist das das ist eine mikrowelle
was macht man mit der mikrowelle mit
einer mikrowelle kann man essen
aufwärmen klaus was ist das das ist eine
schublade
was ist in der schublade in der
schublade sind messer und feuerzeuge
eine schere und flaschenöffner klaus was
ist das das ist ein dosenöffner mit dem
dosenöffner öffnet man dosen aber nicht
jetzt
klaus
was ist das das ist ein holzlöffel ein
löffel aus holz und was ist das das ist
salatbesteck
und was ist das das ist ein messer
schärfer damit kann man ein messer
schärfen
wow klaus zeigt uns jetzt besteck das
ist ein messer
das ist eine gabel das ist ein löffel
[Musik]
das ist auch ein löffel
das ist ein esslöffel das ist ein
teelöffel das alles zusammen ist
besteck klaus zeigt uns das geschirr das
ist ein kuchenteller das ist eine tasse
[Musik]
das ist eine untertasse
das ist ein teglas was ist das das ist
carinas unterhose
nein das stimmt nicht was ist das
das ist ein geschirrhandtuch ich nenne
das trockenen tuch
was macht man mit dem tuch damit kann
man zum beispiel einen teller trocknen
trockenen tuch richtig was ist das das
ist die spüle die spüle ist dreckig das
stimmt
hier ist dreckiges dreckiges zeug denn
klaus und karin haben gerade kekse
gebacken
dann müssen wir abspülen richtig klaus
klaus spült jetzt ab klaus benutzt dafür
einen schwamm richtig einem spiel
schwamm klaus nimmt den schwamm und das
spülmittel und spült ab klaus spülmittel
in das warme wasser
jetzt spielt klaus klaus kannst du diese
schüssel spüren gerne diese schützen
diese schüssel ist dreckig jetzt ist die
schüssel sauber das ist ein spiel tuch
manche nennen es auch trotz doch das ist
die arbeitsplatte ich putze die
arbeitsplatte ab was ist das das ist ein
wasserkocher
damit kocht man wasser
[Musik]
es passiert nichts
das wasser fängt an zu kochen
das stimmt klaus was ist das das ist
küchenrolle das ist eine küchenrolle das
ist papier mit dem man sauber machen
kann mach das doch mal klaus was ist das
das ist ein schneidebrett kannst du mir
den pilz schneiden sehr gerne
klaus hat den pilz mit dem messer
geschnitten auf dem schneidebrett
richtig jetzt darf ich s spüle
das ist ein toaster mit dem toaster
postet man brot wenn der stecker drin
wäre da ist das tust
das ging aber schnell hmm lecker
klaus was ist hier
hier befindet sich der müll im meer
sag mal warum sind da zwei mülleimer
wir trennen dem müll nach was nach den
vorgaben die uns das gesetz vorschreibt
[Musik]
ok und was ist links links befindet sich
der sogenannte rest und rechts rechts
sind die verpackungen die in den so
genannten gelben sack müssen
okay das war der mülleimer
was ist das das ist noch ein mülleimer
was ist da drin hallo was ist in diesem
kleinen mülleimer
das ist der kompostierbare müll der
sogenannte bio müll richtig das kann man
doch noch essen klaus guten appetit
[Musik]